Let's go back to the reader and jump into the normal.
distribution example
now how would you know whether you have to
use this a cmf?
Or cumulative probably function or a PDF.
for continuous RVs
You have to look at the question.
This question is saying what that X?
It's experiments is within.
one standard deviation or you can rephrase this as
between
like contained
You know between the first quantile.
within the mean
okay, so it's not one standard
deviation away towards the left wants to
standard deviation to the right. So these two quantiles.
This is where the inequality comes in.
This is where these two inequalities come come in. Okay,
so that's the
That's of course the probability function.
And we ask you that X.
is within
one standard deviation from
the mean
towards the left and one standard deviation from the
mean towards the right.
By the way in the slides, there's a there's a look
table for all of these characters. What's what
mu means what Sigma means what all of
these characters mean? You can always look them up.
mu refers to the population mean
Sigma refers to the population
standard deviation
Okay.
so
what we want to do.
when we plot
the
the values of the random variable it's experiments and
it's probabilities on a plot like
an x and y axis.
We have to shift it.
So that it's mean is zero again.
If you looked at the if you looked at the previous
example with the what the
with the flash drives, for example, the mean wasn't
zero it was we had random variables 1
2 4 8 and 16
in order to use the normal distribution
so that we can
determine the probability
that
it's experiments fall within one standard deviation
or two standard deviations. We have to shift the probability distribution
to its Center.
In order to do that we use something called the standardization formula.
There's a formula that gets your
random variable to be standardized where it's mean
shift to zero.
That is the z letter that you're looking at.
so by standardizing
the random variable
by standardizing the random variable we are able to then set
its standard deviation or rather.
You know actually determine whether it's whether it's
experiments fall Within.
One standard deviation to the left one strategation to
the right.
Okay, and then we have this.
this function
It's five function. It is called the now.
Phi is
It also a CDF. So also
see the F but instead of P. We use this Greek letter
of Phi and it is specifically for the standard
normal distribution. So we have the normal probability.
No the normal so this is
your mouthful. We have the normal probability distribution, but when
you standardize the normal distribution
He call it a standard normal distribution. That's when it's me has shifted
to zero.
Then when you want to take the CDF.
Of the standardized normal distribution. You
also have to use a standardized cumulative distribution
function or standardized see the f
and that's what this Phi stands for.
So Z is
z is actually X after you
have standardized it.
and Phi is p
for your standardized random variable
I I want to show you how we arrive at these numbers. This is
where integration comes into play. I'm going to show you
the formula for the standardized CDF.
We'll go we'll switch to wall from alpha so
we can calculate the formula.
so, you know what what this is actually
doing to your
to these quantities
But once you have standardized your random variable.
once you've taken your ex
And you've normalized it.
To get Z now you can find.
the
the probability or the cumulative property
probability
whether it's one standard deviation away from the mean or two standard deviations
over if we want however many standard deviations. We want away
from me, although you for a normal distribution. You don't
want to go past three you go past three then
the thing that you're looking at is highly varied
and
if it's if you're using it to influence your business decision,
you would probably not want to go forward with that particular.
Sample space those that collection of experiments. So
here we're looking at you can see that once we
have our standardized random variable we
can then.
Calculate for two standard deviations. That's what
minus 2 here means and what positive 2 here means?